non sto più facendosi of thieves perché
uscirà ufficialmente il 20 marzo e la
beta era soltanto il 15 20 per cento del
gioco finale quindi non avete visto per
la mente niente
nel frattempo la serie la sospendo
perché non si può più accedere alla beta
e quindi aspettiamo il 20 marzo
siamo sul fuoco postman by paul lautsi
kingdom knicks hanno fatto sta roba
sulla scia di getting over it in teoria
pensa quanto può essere figo e interplay
her name 1 stufo di ste cose che però se
non le gioca e fanno i tuoi desideri
sono stati esauditi si è piccoli shiuan
to deliver e b contro un prendi un
desiderio che vuoi consegnare diventerà
realtà fa bene quindi io devo consegnare
il mio desiderio tubi è insomma essere
fantastica e un arrosto mangiano c'è
bisogno voglio essere un fluffy unicorn
avere ogni tipo di pizza che voglio ogni
volta è gratis
direi che ci sta deriva di switch ok ma
io devo a cena proprio alla madonna che
cosa devo fare devo andare avanti e tipo
getting over il solo con un poco già mi
sta mettendo l'anziano non anche
iniziato lega perfetto io mi impegno
sempre per trovare giochi di questo
genere so che vi piacciono so che la
qualità video ludica e questa per l'amor
di dio non so come ho fatto a non
scoprirlo prima il problema io e
l'apposito consegnare la posta col fuoco
se la domani tutti i postini non hanno
il poco mi incazzo quindi l'app la posta
e in quella letterina rossa li capito
quindi quella piccola letterina c'è
scritto che voglio diventare un unicorno
e l'avere ogni tipo di pizza ogni volta
che voglio bene molto chiaro ragazze o
superare un paio di ostacoli ma in
questa roba si fa a tempo giusto ma ci
devo mettere il meno tempo possibile
molto chiaro vi dico solo che record
mondiale di sto gioco per salve mi sa
che lui non c'è arrivato alla fine
questo prezzo presentimento volevo dirvi
ragazzi giusto per mortificare ancora un
attimo e che il record mondiale visto
gioco e di un minuto e 0 7 secondi che
io sono a questo punto il campione del
mondo aveva già finito il gioco bene ciò
che ci sono anche i campioni del mondo
su sti giochi poi diretta di la risposta
è si
non capisco il perchè prova perché è ok
la marchesa alto guardalo fenomeno ma mi
chiama si sposta pure ci mancava solo
che si spostasse guarda dai che ho fame
di andare a mangiare lega ha dominato
questo un barile ok perfetto perfetto
chiara h perfetto ma ragazzi
no ok siamo caduti però effettivamente
non avevo fatto troppa strada quindi ho
visto di pregio mettiamola così scusate
ma in un gioco normale mi sarei
incazzatissimo ma sapendo come getting
over it mi va bene così che scavalca
come ho fatto prima impossibile che
desiderio avevi tu nella busta zio avere
gli scritti di favi j
bisogna finire almeno avere la capacità
di finire i giochi di merda per avere
quattro mini di scritti di allora
capiamoci un cartello di di prendere un
cartello non è difficile il cartello
cartello è sempre ok poi c'è quello in
quel pezzettino in diagonale
eccolo perfetto c'era un pezzettino
stream insito in diagonale dovevo
prendere quello di temi invece normale
cavate ok no no no no no se capita mazza
ok perfetto perché le minacce funzionano
piano destra destra no va bene anche
così se ci arrivi non ci arrivi allora
vede mai nessuno glie li trovo sti
giochi di me cava cà guarda ma poi tutto
questo per un desiderio da deficienti
c'è mio dio
ok a me non ci sono arrivati dai match
ecco una ragazza botta di culo tremendo
ha avuto qua mi sono salvato non sono
anch'io come l'ho fatto prima di entrare
gli esattamente come è impossibile come
un fatto non ci sia lì dai tutta una
vacca indecorosa dai porca eva sono
tornato pure io che ho cliccato per
tornare indietro nel browser
vediamo quanto tempo riesco a arrivare
dov'ero prima soprattutto per il fatto
che raccorda il mondo è un minuto e 8
cioè in un minuto e 0 8 secondi hanno
finito sto gioco io sono neanche
arrivato al punto di prima figurati
capiamoci nel mondo dell'universo come
ho fatto come sono salito la prima volta
come minchiam a guardarmi fare gira
guarda
lasciamo perdere cioè non so come fa
veramente ci ho messo un'ora e mezza per
rifare la stessa maledettissima cosa un
deficiente si può fare qua e devo
saltare l'altra parte senza dondolare il
coema ma è impossibile perfetto un
fenomeno un fenomeno
no non è vero
no non è vero 2 sonora no no no no a
finire così e un privilegio magari
pietro morph incastrato nella casella
della posta
ma io lo giuro su quello che volete io
mi impegno per trovare ste cagate poi le
gioco e mi e l'impianto di giocarci ogni
volta così posso farvi al power 8.000
episodi di minecraft non sono più
tranquillo no non posso anche dire le
parolacce che poi prix video wi fi milan
fuori dal family friendly rega non posso
anche dire quello quindi diciamo
acciderbolina i postini avevo fatto
prima no detto no no no non un buco c'è
un buco di 4 porta ieri no no no
t'ammazzo ok ok piano come avevo fatto
prima
ok occhio cani candy candy nostra parte
del calcio perfetto perfetto occhio ai
un favore di cadere da un momento
all'altro ragazzo santa sale sopra casa
ok che nel cammino nel camino ficcano la
lettera è l'urlo scherzavo o ce la fa e
consegnarlo no stavo cadendo giù mi
seppur incastrato gioca gatte a parte
sono riuscito non ho visto il finale
perché mi è tornato indietro quindi
ragazzi spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto
la schermata finale era semplicemente il
messaggio che io avevo lasciato prima di
consegnare la lettera mi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cosa mi piace anche quali sono
seguiti dalla descrizione so se poi si
chiede era ci vediamo a un prossimo
video
beh ragazzi è la prossima volta che mi
viene in mente di giocare una roba del
genere tramortite mi prima come un
badile e grazie
[Musica]